I think play is important because you
lose your ego and we live ruled by our
egos and our super egos and rules and I
should I shouldn't I should I shouldn't
all day long and when you play that goes
away because you have a focus that is
not on yourself and I think in life we
crave those moments when we lose
ourselves for a country that's as
obsessed with selfhood and celebrity and
and personhood and and identity I think
the great irony is that the happiest
moments of our lives are when we lose
ourselves and people lose themselves in
so many ways they lose themselves when
they take a jog and all of a sudden you
hear that zone you lose yourself in love
you lose yourself what do I have sex you
lose yourself when you're just engaged
in nature you know that these are the
moments that we crave and i think i have
always been interested in that moment
and for me it's come when I've been part
of a group and and I think it's because
I did theater as a kid and I always
found that moment when you could be with
a group of people and it didn't matter
you didn't matter anymore and of course
you matter because you're bringing all
of your heart and your soul in your mind
to it but you're involved in something
larger than yourself and what's
beautiful about the theater is you
always get to begin again and I think as
a director I love that that you always
get to start again and you're not
starting again like this you know back
to the same place you're beginning again
and again and again so everything you do
your building on and everything that you
experience in life you can pour into
your next endeavor so I feel very lucky
that I'm in a profession where whatever
i'm thinking learning feeling stretching
my brain experiencing family life health
problems politics all of that is fodder
for how you can be a better artist so
that all comes into play when you're in
a room with other people and you can
create something out of nothing it's
it's that you know making the invisible
visible which is a very precious thing
that we do naturally as kids we see it
all the time and and that's what I said
earlier about audience you know an
audience actually they want to play too
they want to they want to be engaged
being engaged is in a way playing is
being allowed a space where you can lose
yourself and you can participate and it
doesn't mean Interactive theater I can
be sitting in a chair and watching a
great scene between directors and I'm
participating and I'm losing myself and
I'm engaging and i'm playing i'm kidding
i'm helping to toss that ball back and
forth you know that invisible ball and
and the more that I mean I feel the more
in the theater that an audience feels
like if those actors toss the ball to me
I could toss it back or if I toss that
ball on stage they toss it back that
there's that connection the more engaged
we are so I'm always looking for those
moments where I think it's why I like
musicals because you know we don't sing
in life right we just don't so it's it's
a it's a a theatrical point of view and
there's a collusion with everyone in the
room that this is not real but we're all
going to suspend our disbelief and
imagine and play